welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information on how difficult it
is to go about your daily routine when
you know at any moment a portal could
open in the middle of downtown and an
alien army could come streaming into
your city with the sole purpose of
destroying the planet better get to
those emails my name is jessica clemens
and i'm here today with the off-screen
producer brandon hello jessica i'm so
excited to be here with you today yes
brandon i'm very excited to talk about a
very
hot topic a very hot topic a very big
question we have today something
something uh a little heavy maybe i
don't know we'll we'll get into it we'll
see yeah you ready to do this yes let's
let me put on my glasses so i can get
rid of glasses
really
okay so today we're going to take a big
look at what it's like to live in the
mcu you know so much has happened in the
mcu since its inception way back in 2008
over the years the films have pretty
much taken place like in present day up
until end game when they kind of jumped
ahead five years uh and then after the
events of hawkeye and uh spiderman no
way home most recently you know they're
they're going into 2025 in the mcu okay
but ever since like tony stark was
revealed to be iron man uh at a press
conference to dr strange and you know
spider-man sewing up the multiverse uh
putting it back together uh after
breaking it themselves uh a lot has
happened to our heroes in the mcu but
what is life like for those everyday
people just walking around in the
streets just trying to do their business
what's it like living on the ground
living in the shadows of these
extraordinary beings okay it all leads
us to this week's big question jessica
how terrifying is it to be a civilian in
the mcu
how do they live their lives i honestly
can only imagine it's the same fear as
the people and the boys have where like
right ran through a human that'd be my
biggest fear is like how many times am i
going to get ran through
like yes how many times am i going to go
the dc eu kind of touched on it right
with like we saw what it was like on the
ground level with superman uh fighting
and knocking down buildings and all that
stuff but what's that like to be a
person they've been through so much they
know a lot about what's going on so
let's jessica let's go through all these
like big events uh
and see if we can figure out like what's
it like to really live your day-to-day
life in the mcu yes we know the majority
of the public's not uh aware of
everything that's been going on
with like shield and the avengers and
everything else on like a superhero
scale that we as the audience know they
don't know all that but there are some
things you can't hide from the public
you know there's some some big concepts
and some threats that humanity is
grappling with in the mcu and that's
gotta affect public life and somehow
right yeah just a little bit
yeah just a little bit let's start with
a big one okay the existence of aliens
okay that's something big if you're
living in the mcu you gotta wrap your
head around that right you know there's
confirmed
alien life out there and the first time
they meet that most people meet these
aliens is the battle in new york okay
just imagine you're living your life you
know you you you don't know that there's
aliens out there you think there might
be aliens out there but they're mt are
they're empty they're empty
he's doing it mt's doing that
so you you think there might be aliens
out there but when you picture them
you're picturing like e.t right a nice
friendly alien turn on your heart lie
doing the finger point okay but no it's
a portal opens up and shitari come
streaming through starts shooting people
blowing up buildings or a giant worm in
the sky that's that's that's your first
contact with aliens uh for most of
humanity how crazy is that okay how
crazy is that i would my first idea
would be okay i gotta seduce them i
gotta get them that's your first idea
it's not a bad idea you guys you guys
i'll take i'll take it i'll take it from
here and then i seduce them no but that
is probably the most
and we saw it with um and kate bishops
and hawkeye just like half your house
and this is people living in mansions
living in like
very much lavish lifestyle yeah lavish
lifestyle you can't hide from this half
your building gets cut into half and
you're just like hmm i can fall to my
death like 400 like 400 feet below or i
can just like get swallowed by an alien
worm and also i guess when i think of
aliens i wouldn't think of it's gonna be
as sweet as e.t but i wouldn't have
thought they would all come in like a
full brigade like i wouldn't be like
that's what you're hoping right you're
hoping that's not what's gonna happen
they kind of talked about uh they had
that like uh that's one thing i liked
about invincible that series right yeah
the episode where the aliens they're in
a faster timeline and they keep showing
up and it seems like the people in the
city they're like so used to it at this
point they're like oh well
i guess we gotta deal with this again
today i'm gonna be late to work this is
another alien invasion today just open
your umbrella and be like when the
cement falls on me i guess i can't be
stopped by this i wouldn't live and it's
so comedic to be like yeah you're just
gonna live a normal life you're just
gonna get on the subway and go into
downtown every day going into downtown
is more than a battle it's literally
just like am i gonna survive because
an alien could come kill me that's why
i'm like seduce them
you're not gonna be able to live with
them but maybe you can try to get on
their side it's a real shame that like
the xandarians didn't come first very
peacefully and be like hey you know
we're aliens we look a lot like you guys
we're pretty nice we got some great tech
no the first aliens that most of the
public meets are the chitauri and
they're pissed
and they're angry and they're here to
fight and and jessica's gonna try and
seduce him but they're not that good
looking i mean they're muscular they're
muscular but they're not that good
you don't want to kiss such atari
think about it that's a pretty heavy
thing that they're dealing with that
they're walking around with uh another
another kind of crazy thing that
happened that we have to remember
is that remember when natasha romanoff
aka black widow everyone knows she
released during uh captain america uh
winter soldier she released all of these
like shield and hydro files to the
public just put them on the internet uh
and that's that's led to some pretty
crazy things that already happened like
zemo got some of that information uh the
flag smashers all that stuff it
basically took down shield you know i
mean shield being infiltrated by hydra
also took it down but that what she did
like destroyed shield one of the biggest
uh you know government organizations
on the planet how do how does the public
deal with that i mean i think we know
that that even if you tell people what's
actually going on they just go about
their daily lives but that's a pretty
heavy thing they got it but that's more
heavy this is different and also because
this involves them so that's when it
when people draw the line they're like
oh whatever and then you're like but
this
could potentially this is the only
people protecting you and it's like wait
a minute wait i'm ready the more we talk
about this the more my plans don't seem
like they make sense because i would
just become a villain at this point i'd
be like who's going to protect me i'd be
like who's protecting me if we have
freaking thunderbolt ross who's like
trying to make super soldiers again i'd
be like who who's going to protect me
who's here to help me because i'm just a
person that works at like jamba juice
you can't you can't be prepared for that
you just have to like
i guess be okay with it just be okay i
mean if you got to imagine there were
tons of like memes that came out of like
the secret hydra and secret shield files
right that's the only way you can deal
with it is with memes that's the only
way what if you're working for them and
all the files got out what if you were
just an accountant and all the files got
out and you're like [ __ ] this is what
i've been working with
this is what i've been doing i have to
go to work tomorrow yeah all my files
got released all my numbers oh my god
i'm not going to work tomorrow no i'm
not going to work tomorrow oh my
goodness numbers jill's done all my
numbers that's a very interesting idea
though jessica i hope i hope more super
villains come about because of these
like released files like that helps put
even more like nefarious tech out into
the world all these super villains
finding things in the files that they
can use uh to grow their evil ways there
you go yeah it helps i like it hey it
helps if you're a villain out there just
uh do it but don't harm me go blow up
the moon and don't pardon me you don't
know him reeva go blow up the moon who
needs the moon
[Music]
okay jessica we've got a lot of
negatives on this list and we're gonna
get even more negatives but there's got
to be at least one
positive thing for the civilians of the
of the mcu and that's going to be the
major tech advancements that they're
getting right uh just just from stark
industries alone you know they're
rolling out like cutting-edge
technologies that must have trickled
down to the public in some aspect right
you know they get they get those energy
upgrades there's like repulsor tech
there's nano tech there's medical
advancements i mean roadie's walking
around i would hope that somehow some of
that has gotten into the public maybe
flying commercially is a little better
now you know what i mean maybe the
planes are a little faster you get to
your destination faster there's some
good things from from the mcu right
until it's put in the hands of the wrong
people
that always happens
that's that's the hard part
wakanda um was like we're gonna open up
the world now to everybody i was like
okay i'm here for it but also what
happens when the wrong people get a hold
of it which is bound to happen and it's
not even like the wrong people it's like
again someone with just like a little
ounce of evil in them
learns about all this in class and it's
just like hmm
now i'm gonna create a bomb like it's
just like
example not a good example but a man
like peacemaker in the peacemaker series
his dad has created all this junk for
peacemaker to do that is inherently
gonna be bad and
is just blind to it but he's just like
giving him that world of technology has
created an ignorant person that is just
making doing bad things peacemaker at
the beginning he was doing bad things he
was trained by a racist so it's like oh
he's just ignorant to the fact that like
these are bad things because i was
raised by a bad person so if an evil
person
made an offspring and taught them only
to do evil things they're gonna take all
that stuff from wakanda and just create
bad things you guys i love a good
villain but i don't like a racist which
i think we can all agree i'm agreed well
that's a great point though jessica uh
even the reveal of wakanda has got to be
crazy right you got to be thinking are
there other super advanced countries out
there that i don't know about that in a
away yes i would be air i would be
killmonger like i'd be like why were you
guys hiding the entire time i'd be like
do you know what happened to the rest of
us i have horrible stories to tell you
and you just sat there
enjoying your time you didn't even
invite me so like yeah exactly and then
i would also yeah my like weird i'd be
like what who else is doing this
everyone must be doing this i need to
know i just want a nano tech jacket
because i'm always forgetting my jacket
places i just want a jacket that's
always there when i need it and when i
don't need it it goes away that's all i
need they should just reward every
civilian one like wish
you get one piece of technology
everybody gets one because i'd be like
can i have really fast sneakers i'm like
can i have shoes that make me run fast
like that i like that one more than the
jacket
all right all right
you see when you're cold you can't
outrun the cold oh that's true that's
true that's true that's enough good
stuff let's talk about more of the bad
stuff in the mcu uh
a few major cities uh had big
destructive events okay you know we
already mentioned the battle in new york
that's pretty heavy that's something
that that's going to like weigh on
people's minds sokovia do you remember
sokovia
i remember the whole city got lifted
into the sky and almost fell back to
earth and destroyed it how many days off
of work do you get for that for that
event happening you get two days off of
work and then you gotta go back to your
job
i just don't come back
i'll just act like i'm dead
[Laughter]
sorry i can't come in today dealing with
the fear that my city might get raised
into the sky in san francisco you got
like scott lang running around as giant
man if i saw a giant man i'm in i'm into
that one so if you could choose
locations on the map
i'm into that one because the giant
hello kitty pez dispenser i'd be trying
to drag it home like i would be trying
to drag [ __ ] and that one was pretty
cool and also like well not so cool but
just like cool to see um the shanxi the
battle in san francisco um with the bus
like there's a lot like if you could
choose locations knowing what previously
happened there in the mcu i would choose
san francisco because we also get to see
the freaking
eternals we could see them the head of
giant come out of nowhere and i'd be
like
did you see that girl get yanked from a
park into the sky
that girl got yeted into the sky and her
her boyfriend is just screaming
like i'd be like i saw that i was at
that park walking my dog so far san
francisco they've had some crazy stuff
happen but nothing too yeah insane we're
not new york not yet we're not new york
bay area is not new york
well then you had then you had like uh
during spider-man far from home you had
venice prague and london all have like
what people thought were these
elementals attacking them and then it
gets revealed that it's drones that are
then like later uh confiscated by the
government and then you think it's a
teenager who did it but maybe your
memory's been wiped now so i don't know
how much they remember about what
happened
in those cities i'm not quite sure we'll
have to find out there and then think
about washington dc remember uh captain
america the winter soldier you have
these flying helicarrier helicarriers
come out of the a lake and then all of a
sudden they start crashing back down
like what is going on what is my
government doing how am i supposed to
live my life i know x-men aren't here
yet but what about that like individual
that like that one individual that is a
mutant that didn't get their [ __ ] race
like erased and they're just like a
conspiracy theorist now just because
they're the ones that remember
everything and no one's gonna believe
you so you're just like and it's like
there's the x-men gene like or the
mutant gene there's like so many
variables that like it could be so
minimal or it could be very big imagine
sky high if you will so it could be like
something really stupid or something
really cool so it's like someone that
doesn't know that they have that gene
yet that is straight up just like i was
just uh like that just didn't work on me
because it's impenetrable for me like i
i'm just like a strong human being
whatever i remember all these things all
these things happen i'm not a conspiracy
theorist like this is real so boom
another villain another literally just
me because you guys made me look crazy
and i wasn't crazy i'm not crazy
so you're you're an mcu civilian you're
walking around you're worried about
aliens you know the government's been up
to bad stuff
you got your fast shoes but that's it
okay and now you're worried that maybe
today my city's gonna get destroyed by
some crazy event now i got another thing
to throw on your plate okay jessica yeah
the existence of gods okay
you know
[Music]
gods are real in the mcu or maybe
they're aliens i don't know it's
complicated but we know at least that
the general public is aware of thor
they're probably aware of loki because
of the events of the battle in new york
i'm sure someone pointed out that loki
was leading this charge or something we
love all kinds but loki you don't belong
at least one or two gods from myths
they've heard about are are true so how
does this square up with how people view
religion i would i would assume there
are people worshiping thor as like a
church absolutely right 100
my biggest thing about thor which i'm
always irritated about is if he was like
true to be there would definitely be a
like a cult for thor well i'll be
hanging around the arena grounds if you
need someone to worship the ground you
walk on
bye
and there would also be people that
follow him religiously like there would
just be fan girls oh my god it's them
there would be everything for thor but
i would be like notice how he's not
bringing upon the rain for the farmers
this is why i'm the villain this is why
i'm in the village
that's what i would be like he's like
lord of thunder and i'd like can you
bring rain for my crops
i'd be like yes it's 20 22. and we still
have rain he's the lord of thunder how
are you gonna give thunder without rain
am i stupid am i a scientist no no no no
am i i mean i think i have one or the
other i think that was like a story line
in the comics either the ultimates
universe when they did ultimates and at
first they thought he was just a crazy
person and then they realized he was a
god but there were people like
worshiping and when they made new asgard
in the comics when it was in like
oklahoma i think
i think there were people trying to get
to there that's what i think would be
interesting to see in thor 11 thunder
where it seems like there's going to be
some sort of like amusement park there
in tonesburg where people are going to
be coming there as like a tourist
destination we know the public's aware
of new asgard slash stonesburg because
in spiderman no way home we saw like a
little news graphic about it so there's
got to be people like coming there like
religiously like oh yeah i worship thor
now you know i was a baptist but now
yeah now i'm up north i worship
when you see him you're like oh his dad
exists too like the god exists right so
yeah i hope they do and there's gotta be
people in the mcu who are like well if
thor is an alien does that mean
jesus is an alien like what's going on
here who's real who's not real i want to
know now i i would hate to be a a
religious leader in the mcu because you
got to have to answer a lot of questions
a lot of questions they're like well
thor came to my city just yesterday but
jesus has him
what is my tithing going towards okay
that's what i want to do
excuse me i need to know i need to see i
need some i need some roof here
[Music]
lock and load
has that been a big question yet does
christianity exist and
well we know it exists in the mcu
there's religious icon or iconograph
icon iconography i know what you're
talking about i can't say it now because
i'm thinking about it iconic uh iconic i
can't i just go just go i can't yeah
kind of iconic icon iconic like conor
iconography we know there's religion in
the mcu because they've referenced it
there's religious iconography
[Music]
uh here and there but yeah i i would
really want like a a movie that's just a
two-hour sit down with all the religious
leaders
talking about like how we're gonna
square this up with our people uh this
is a bit much well let's talk about the
most incredible thing that's happened to
people in the mcu and that's got to be
the work of the mad titan himself thanos
okay thanos was right maybe maybe not i
don't know who can say uh this was
clearly the most impactful event as
we've seen it bleed into every post in
game release from marvel every movie and
tv show has like acknowledged this event
and how big it was i mean
huge you know people disappearing for
five years and then coming back right um
and as we saw on shows like wanda
division and the falcon and winter
soldier the public's aware of
thanos they're aware of the battle that
happened at the compound they know about
these people and what they did and what
thanos was and what he did but how does
anyone move past this like it is so
insane i love that people it's touched
upon so much afterwards of like what if
another one comes like what happens when
it happens again and people have and
that's been like people's argument all
the time in mcu civilians being like it
could happen again like what happens
when it happens again who's going to
protect us from this like you guys are
not doing your job um and
as a civilian i feel like there is it
depends on who the person is but i feel
like with myself i would just be like it
well i guess to people it felt like it
was just like
this right it was like well to the
people who disappeared yeah
the people
see that's the thing i would pray that i
was the person that disappeared
[Music]
i would pray i was one of the people
that were snapped because i would just
come back and be like nothing happened
but my power's off and my house has been
robbed but like if it was
if i was if i was not snapped you just
turn into um
what's the comic book why the last man
like i would turn into why the last man
i would be a savage like i would
straight up
i would and i would be like i'd like
here is my wares if you would like to
buy it over here stranger got something
that might interest you
like i would be weird you're a merchant
yeah
yeah and i would have it on my back and
honestly i'd be trying to travel hello
traveler would you like my warehouse i
would be so weird speaking of where's
traveler
my i interest you win an apple and then
when it came to i don't know if i could
go back i would just be like i'm a crazy
person i know it wasn't that much time
but i'd be like you guys don't
understand i was alone i was traveling
with my wares
i keep saying i mean maybe maybe your
boss blipped away and then you get five
years and then he comes back and he like
emails you and he's like i'm gonna need
you back in tomorrow buddy and you're
like no you blipped away i've moved on i
don't even have a phone anymore i have
dude do we have internet like it's like
no i i would be like dude i'm
i'm all the way in africa like i'm not
coming back i'm riding in a giraffe so
after all that you still can't change me
into a giraffe i am glad that the mcu is
addressing this issue so much because
there's so many like unanswered
questions with it and how crazy it all
was you know we saw like the support
group uh in endgame yes people like
living through it and i imagine there's
got to be way more support groups like
with everyone coming back and you know
there's something falcon and winter
soldier really touched on you know with
the flag smashers and all that now that
we've seen the world differently should
we go back to that should we continue on
like nothing ever happened like how
insane it must be and yeah just to your
point just to worry that it could just
happen again at any moment any second it
could just happen again you don't know
what's going on out there you're just
walking around in the street
that if anything with the flag smashers
that brought a lot of attention to like
we really split off as like a human race
once that happened um and different and
not even putting the superheroes in the
same category it gave everyone a purpose
after that snap of just like what how
are you gonna live your life what are
you gonna do now i'm not trying to
spread the gospel of it but like it gave
everybody like a purpose it was just
like what are you going to do now are
you going to go back to your daily life
are you going to try to make like a
bigger
print on the world yeah i don't want to
go back to my my day job pushing papers
i got to make a difference now i'm going
to be a super villain i'm going to be a
super villain are we considering the
flag smashers villains was that like
they i don't like the way they were
going about what they were yeah i don't
like the way they conduct their business
yeah at a point but they had to be
listened to i i was there to listen to
it i was like okay let me listen to your
argument and i get where you're coming
from but you guys are murdering innocent
lives right now
terrorism is never the answer
but you know we do we do need to listen
to people better we need to do a better
job listening people are traumatized in
the mcu let's help them out a little bit
we need to do a better job of listening
that is
to sum up the flag
so now you're living with this you know
about aliens who know about god's you
know about your terrible government you
know about
uh
thanos and uh there's a
whole cosmic possibilities out there
let's talk about what happened during
one division really fast okay
uh maybe maybe everyone doesn't know
what happens but that whole neighborhood
right they remember being under her
control they're pissed when they wake up
right they're mad at her you know one of
these people is going to go on tick-tock
and start doing all these rants about
like the scarlet witch she was in my
town she brain wiped me she made me work
this job she made me
walk around my house she maybe just sit
there silently she was messing with my
mind she was in my head like people are
going to find out about this and be
really pissed off and really scared and
this is something that the x-men comics
have always dealt with right the fear of
mutants people are going to be more
afraid i think of what these people can
do and if they're going to start
introducing mutants that can really kick
off the fear they have of other people
right yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes as a civilian in that show as a
civilian i wasn't but if let's take
let's say i'm in california when that
stuff was happening in jersey i would
have been like wow my first reaction
i've been like wow someone needs to keep
an eye on her like someone needs to
watch out and then they're like well now
she's gone i'd be what do you mean now
she's gone
you let her walk away what the heck
these people what the hell are you
talking about she she did that like i'd
be and that because we don't know i
don't think the civilians really know
what we saw we just know that a
superhero went to this small town took
over the minds of every civilian there
and forced them to live a life that was
traumatizing to them because they could
see they were in the sunken place they
could see what was happening but they
couldn't come out so it was like to hear
that i would be like what the hell i bet
there's a superhero that's a villain i'd
be like there's a superhero that can
take over my mind nah nah
i have a tattoo over here i'd also
i wouldn't i wouldn't trust like my
neighbors anymore oh yeah
look at carl look how he's mowing the
yard he must be mind controlled right
now are you controlled carl
they're like okay what you're not gonna
kill me carl i'll get you first i'm
gonna kill you carl can we get you to
lower our neighbor now i mean he didn't
do anything to you yet
i wouldn't be able to trust myself
anymore like why am i doing the things
that i'm doing am i in control is
someone controlling my mind
that is a real thing that i was like i
would be like i'm in a simulation at all
time at all times i'd be like how do i
know who i'm talking to is actually
there sorry i missed that meeting boss i
was just uh i was mind controlled and i
you know i had to play playstation 5 all
day i couldn't i couldn't help it
it's just crazy i don't know maybe
there's a witch in my neighborhood i
don't know maybe there's i think there's
a witch in my neighborhood that's your
excuse oh i can't come in there's a
witch in my neighborhood she controlled
me
yeah i don't know i guess she stopped i
don't know let's talk about the eternals
you brought them up a couple times i
don't know what people know about the
eternals right i don't even know what a
lot of the heroes on earth know about
the eternals or or celestials really we
know that cosmic characters are well
aware of the celestials all the
guardians all them we know that thor
probably is i don't know if he's
bothered to mention it to anybody uh on
earth but who knows we know that like
wong and all the mystic arts people they
know about celestials because wong told
us all about them most people have no
clue about them okay and then when
eresham shows up in the sky okay
what is going on and this is not long
after
everyone just came back from the blip
right yeah it's like a few months later
i'd be like oh
and like they just you know they showed
us it was just this park in london right
you know and like 10 people in the park
how big are shim was like a quarter of
the population of earth probably saw
that guy and they were like what's going
on you know dade whitman is a normal
human man well he's a black knight by
that we'll get it yeah but he's just for
the most part a normal human who's
hanging out with this chick cersei that
he's really into she's got this weird
teenage friend who keeps telling him all
these crazy stories about how they've
lived forever blah blah blah he finds
out that she's a robot from space and
he's like cool with it he's like go do
your thing go with your old flame that's
fine i'm cool all that happens she comes
back and he's like oh she's she's
telling him the story now there's a big
stone celestial on the ocean no no big
deal right
he's like fine let's just go for a walk
in the park as you said she gets yeaded
away
he's supposed to just go on with his
life everyone
in the world is supposed to be like wait
there's giant space
cosmic god robots out there and you want
me to go to my job tomorrow yeah no you
want me to go to my job tomorrow
you want me to go to my nephew's
christening and there's a giant space
got out there who could just show up in
the sky whatever he wants the amount of
people and we're downplaying it but the
amount of people in the universe that
would have ptsd because of that snap and
then that [ __ ] comes up that would
trigger something in me so yeah so
massive i would just go ah they'd be
like control this woman at the park i
bet he's back they're coming i don't
want to disappear for five years like
i'd be going crazy and that
freaking thing is scary that's when i
would start as a person start
researching as much as i could in
religion because the eternals they don't
exist to us right we don't know much
about them but they do exist in history
books like they exist they were there
and we just took it and like made it
something else that it was
like we just assumed it was like stories
being passed down but it was because
these people were living through it all
yeah and that's i mean loki that's what
we're doing with new rockstars we're
like reading into like every theory and
being like this must be someone but like
in the b like i would go read the bible
and be like um ezekiel like i wonder if
that's a god today let's go find ezekiel
where is he where's my i heard that he's
somewhere what's your name
i don't know how any organized religion
would still exist in the mcu after all
that's gone on i mean people probably
want answers and they want comfort and
they want to feel safe and they want to
feel like they got a grasp of this
universe that's spinning out of control
that's that's you're right jessica it's
crazy well that might be the and i am a
negative i'm not a negative person i
just like villains i just love a
negative but i think that is a
positivity out of this is that like most
human beings just have faith in
something and you can put that faith
into whatever you want and i think with
through the mcu it shows more outlets in
which to have that faith so like those
that are christian it's like yeah you
can be christian or you can also follow
norse mythology because it actually
turns out to be like very true and
pretty accurate pretty accurate so it's
like you can point with the eternals
like you can have so many outlets to be
like i follow
like athena athena i follow her like
greek mythology turns out to be also
true so it's just like there's so much
outlets for people to have faith in um
whether it's negative or positive but
it's like you can follow a lot of a lot
of religions and i
i root for that well i yeah i didn't
even think about that jessica maybe this
is pushing people more towards religion
who knows like you said there's a lot of
trauma and we're only covering earth
exactly to your point there's planets
out there where one day half the
population disappeared and then five
years later they came back and they have
no idea what happened they're just like
well i guess that was a thing on
gwipgarb
whip
that is true i didn't think about the
poor other planets in 50 years they'll
get news from this planet called earth
or terra or whatever they call it and
they'll be like oh they did something
and it's like okay cool grip garb moves
on i don't know keep calm and grip
garbon i mean the last thing we could
touch on real fast is like spiderman no
way home i don't think anyone was aware
of like the multiverse outside of like
our heroes and stuff but some people in
new york city must have seen the purple
cracks in the sky right that wasn't just
for the people at the statue of liberty
or do you think the mind wipe takes away
the purple cracks i think it does i
think i think
we downplayed what um doctor strange
actually did like he wiped everyone's
mind of um spiderman yes but i also
think he was like i'm just gonna add in
this little little bit of spice bam to
wipe everyone's remember memory of like
there's ghosts coming out of blue cracks
in the sky
no purple cracks they were spared that
at least yeah so i think they kind of
got that wipe too but again if they
didn't i'd be like
where's that wanda at
like someone give me water someone's got
an answer for these look this looks like
that new jersey thing
she's gonna catch a lot of strays every
time something happens i'm gonna be like
where's wanda
wanna max him off you guys gotta get
water in here please please thank you
crazy okay well i think that that's a
pretty good conclusion jessica i mean i
i think it's pretty tough to live in the
mcu you gotta if you're just a normal
person you got a lot got a lot on your
shoulders but you know it's all about
living for today all you can do you
never know when your city's going to get
lifted into the sky or a giant man is
going to come running down your block
and maybe step on you
or you know a different version of
yourself from another dimension comes in
and kills you it could happen any moment
of any day but you just gotta persevere
you know you gotta find your happy place
and you gotta live there oh
there you go
there you go i just feel bad i feel bad
for everyone in the mcu and they
shouldn't have to have day jobs anymore
yeah you guys should too much you guys
should all just become villains let the
hate flow through you yeah i like
jessica's plan of earth becoming just a
battle world
i i think i choose those things because
i'm like i can hold my ground for a
while i'm like i could fight someone off
for a minute you're gonna be the
merchant selling weapons oh yeah i'm
gonna need a weapon you guys need a
weapon you guys need
i i learn how to weld dangerous out
there
i become a welder i blow glass also i
make art you guys can buy some art well
thank you jessica uh before we go on to
the next part of the big question i want
to remind you guys that over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
there's two new shirts inspired by hbo's
peacemaker series there is over the top
as the show is and they're a great
compliment to the other suicide squad
inspired merch that you'll find up on
the site like the king shark backpack or
the dove of peace stickers you know if
you put a dove of peace sticker on
anything it's no longer a weapon of
destruction it makes it a lot
nicer the weapon of peace uh so check
out all the great merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
and before we dive into our bite-sized
questions next some words from the
people that help us bring big question
to you if saving more and spending less
is one of your top goals for 2022 don't
keep paying insane amounts of money
every month for wireless switch to mint
mobile to save this year as the first
company to sell premium wireless service
online only mint mobile lets you
maximize your savings with plans
starting at just fifteen dollars a month
here at new rockstars philip switched to
mint mobile and has saved a ton of money
over all the months he's had the plan by
going online only met mobile passes
significant savings on to you all plans
come with unlimited talk and text and a
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network use your own
phone and keep your same phone number
along with all your existing contacts
with mint mobile choose the amount of
monthly data that's right for you and
stop paying for that data that you never
even use switch to mint mobile and get
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month to get your new
wireless plan for just fifteen dollars a
month and get the plan shipped to your
door for free go to metmobile.com big q
that's mintmobile.com
bigq cut your wireless build to 15 bucks
a month at mintmobile.com big q if
you're selling anything online you're
probably really busy right now but we're
glad you're watching the show so keep at
it online sellers like you need ship
station no matter how much you sell
shipstation makes it super easy to
manage and ship all your orders from all
your sales channels faster cheaper and
more efficiently import orders from any
sales channel and ship with any carrier
you can access discounted shipping rates
and automate just about any shipping
task no matter how you're selling
shipstation funnels all your orders into
one simple interface that you can manage
from anywhere even on your cell phone at
new rockstars shipstation has helped us
save time on the shipping details so we
have more time for making our great
content with shipstation small
businesses can now access the same rates
usually reserved for fortune 500
companies without the contracts or
commitment it's no wonder shipstation
has more five-star reviews than any
other shipping software ship more in
less time just use offer code big
question to get a 60 day free trial
that's two months free of no hassle
stress-free shipping just go to
shipstation.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in big
question at shipstation.com in inner
offer code big question make ship happen
and now into our bite size question
brandon throw it my way please i will
answer only one only one there can be
only one
[Music]
i got one bite-sized question for you
jessica you're beautiful are there any
comic book characters out there that
don't have a tragic backstory this is
from crispy chrissy on discord thank you
for your question crispy crispy well
thank you crispy chris crispy krispy
kreme thank you christmas
having some personal struggles and
sometimes even tragic events is pretty
common among hero origin stories it's
great narrative device that gives the
character humanity along with the reason
and purpose to choose their heroic path
so it's not often you find a happy
origin story for a hero especially in
modern comic book writing one great
example of a non-tragic backstory in the
golden era of comics is actually wonder
woman after being formed from clay she
lives a pretty peaceful and happy life
on themyscira aka paradise island back
in the day then one day steve trevor
crashes and she wins a contest to take
him back to his world and that's how it
begins for her go figure i wish that was
me um
also be informed from clay just means
that you're gonna be you're you're bit
you're the best you're gonna be great
yeah uh
imagine david imagine anything that was
shaped from like
the mold rodance the thinker oh yeah
gorgeous man
gorgeous they were they were carved out
of stone so i don't know if they were
made from clay but they weren't so i see
your point yeah yeah yeah beautiful if
you're playing yeah you're gonna be
beautiful you're gonna be great and
another good example is actually
squirrel girl other than being born with
the tail she doesn't seem to have much
of a tragedy in her backstory i suppose
she might have been picked on at school
but you know who hasn't
who hasn't actually also i grew up with
a girl with a tail if she's watching
this she just had an elongated spine and
it makes a little tail at the end
none of us made fun of her we were like
that's the sickest thing can we see it
and she was like no because it's very
low on my lower back right no you cannot
look at my butt thank you so much we
were really into it we were also kids so
that's good i'm glad to hear you to make
fun of her we should celebrate each
other's differences but yeah you're
right there's a lot of tragedy out there
for our heroes but i guess it's kind of
boring if they just have like a normal
lifestyle well that's the heroes that's
the whole hero's journey that's what
makes them hero yeah you at least one of
your parents have to be passed away
and then
a tragedy stricken and then you come
from gold with that so i mean everybody
has that i have something to fight for
you have something to fight for you
ready for yours yeah you want to ask me
that yeah since i'm only doing one you
ready wire hut so powerful in the star
wars universe says lost crown 22 on
twitter which is a valid question a very
valid question yeah it is a valid
question like you know jabba the hutt
was always an intimidating figure in the
star wars universe until leia brought in
the chains of justice and now in the
book of boba fett we have like the twin
huts asserting their power on the former
bounty hunter turned neighborhood city
councilman uh but why are these large
mostly immobile nearly unintelligible
space slugs so feared and so powerful
how how do they do it
money baby
money money buys a lot of power okay in
the old republic before the times of the
empire the hutt clan or the hutt cartel
or the hutt families whatever you want
to call them they were basically the
masters of organized crime throughout
the galaxy they were able to use their
money and their influence to build a
network of trade uh and that that led to
like their own criminal empire because
they frequently were using bounty
hunters uh to get their own way you know
if something stood in their way they
took care of it uh a lot of force a lot
of killing a lot of intimidation
uh and then when eventually the empire
starts to rise as we saw uh in in the
events of the prequel they worked with
the hutts uh and they were able to
use the trade routes they'd already set
up and use the influence they already
had so the huts were working with the
empire who were also scary so now you're
double scared of the huts right and at
their height there was like this grand
hut council that governed the activities
of two main hutt families uh two main
kind of clans bader came along and
basically killed them all except for
jabba jabba was the head of one of these
hut clans and everyone else was taken
out except for jabba which explains why
he's so feared around the time of return
of the jedi when we meet him because
he's the only hut left he has like all
of the hutt's power and he's working
with the empire
he was the big slug on campus you know
you got to be afraid of this guy and
even though most of the huts we've seen
are pretty much immobile that's because
you know they've been living the easy
life for too long they're they've been
eating too much they've been relaxing
they're not doing the dirty work anymore
if you're like a young strong
active hut you're pretty muscular you're
pretty strong their skin is very thick
it's resistant to corrosive chemicals
it's not resistant to blaster fire it's
hard to stab them it's hard to like dump
acid on them or whatever they're very
strong and most importantly as we saw in
return on the jedi they're resistant to
the jedi mind trick you will bring
captain solo and the wookie to me
you can't you can't do that on them okay
which is kind of a messed up horsepower
for good jedi's to be using i'm just
saying you shouldn't control people's
minds talk about that with wanda even in
a galaxy far far away folks just like
here money talks baby money talks okay
cash rules everything around me gas cash
rules everything around me that's how
the hutts got to power that's how they
kept power uh and that's how they keep
that's why people are so afraid of them
gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous gorgeous
people the huts
beautiful people
when i was watching it when i was ah
when i was watching the book of boba
fett i was like
damn i'd be working for the huts
i'd be like damn i'm gonna be wearing
noises
you'd be selling trinkets for the hugs
and you want to buy some treats yeah you
want to buy some drinks i'm worse than
the guys oh where's the guy in hercules
where he's like wanna buy a sundial and
shows himself i'm that guy so i'm sleazy
so now it is time for our box of scripts
oh box of scraps boxes
box of scraps is always my favorite
because it's just always a very crazy
question like this one today what
existential crisis keeps you up at night
oh boy we've been talking about what
it's like to live in the mcu what's that
like what what what existential crisis
keeps you up at night i mean the real
question is like what doesn't
what doesn't what does it we had a
tsunami warning here in like california
um i literally freaked out i was like my
cat's freaking out she senses something
the other night it was just wind um it
was wind everywhere
i'm always broke um
[Music]
i don't know if that's an existential
crisis i'm like am i just being
it could be because what is rules
everybody cash baby
the huts are coming any moment i mean
jessica you and i both live in
california
location undisclosed somewhere in the
state of california so we have the fear
of earthquakes i mean that's pretty
scary right at the moment the big one
could be coming i lived in 2001
washington state had a horrible
earthquake it was insane and i was so
young i was like oh this is fun but as
an adult i saw the damage it did and
that's the part where i'm like
you know what else is scary volcanoes
because we have
you guys i'm afraid of everything and i
know you're like you're in california
i'm like the volcanoes are erupting the
polar ice caps are melting
greenhouse gases i mean
yes
climate change is a very scary climate
change is a horrible one jessica i grew
up during the times of uh uh dante's
peak slash volcano when the movies made
us afraid of volcanoes just popping up
out of nowhere so i fear i fear the
volcano as well i used to fear volcanoes
growing up in florida even though there
was no way there could ever be a volcano
there i hope i don't know washington
maybe mount st helens when it is erupted
yeah but like i was far away from it and
the ash still hit us it was like you
can't drive we live i live silent hill
you guys
i know that sounds crazy also when i
went to michigan that was the first time
i heard a tornado warning what the [ __ ]
was that noise that's scary
the warnings the warnings for tornadoes
are often we need to
we need to upgrade everything i think
those sirens are so old i literally was
like oh great an apocalypse is coming
the hell mouth has opened up yeah and
now demons are streaming into the sky
god is choosing the best of us the
japanese have developed like better
early warning sound things that they
feel like you need to pay attention but
they don't feel like uh uh the earth is
being swallowed by the darkness it's
true i think the most existential thing
i fear that's pretty crazy and out there
it's like i believe they're called rogue
planets or something like that where
there are these
these planets that are out there in the
solar system that don't have a normal
orbit they're not orbiting a star or
anything they just exist and they kind
of float through space and we're not
aware of them we don't know they're
there we can't see them and the idea
that out of nowhere one of these could
just come slamming into the earth i mean
you
don't it's really scary great now
another thing that that's going to keep
me up at night i look up all these weird
things all the time because i'm just
like what happens when the water bears
turn into something that they weren't
supposed to turn into and decide to
engulf us all like i am truly afraid of
everything and you just added another
one on my list yeah oh my god
you guys that was big question
that was what what a depressing big
question folks so sorry and that's big
question thank you for joining
brandon
that's i'll try to be happy to depress
jessica that was a big question you guys
thank you brandon for joining me and
letting me join you follow brandon at
grin and barrack not grin and barrett
grin and barrick a fun
very clever fun and so it was mine
follow me out under lulu underscore
clemens the joke is like lululemon's the
fitness of peril no one really gets take
it people call me lulu people be like
lulu you're so funny and i'm like said
play on lululemon
follow new rockstars at new rockstars
here on youtube and all social media
platforms and make sure to hit that
notification bell subscribe like and
follow and if you want to continue the
conversation go to new rock stars on
discord it's it's open it's up now you
just have to be over 18. search the new
rockstars discord server and join the
conversation
look at that yeah join us look at us
look at that
thank you so much for having me on a big
question today it was a real treat oh of
course if you want to talk more sad
stuff just let me know
hit us up on twitter and we'll talk sad
all day oh god don't tweet me sad things
happy things it's scary out there bye
folks bye
what's that like to be a person you
don't want to kiss a chitari
think about it you get two days off of
work and then you gotta go back to your
job
i just don't come back
i'll just act like i'm dead well if
thor's an alien does that mean
jesus is an alien
i'm all the way in africa like i'm not
coming back i'm writing a giraffe
that's right if you're if
you're saving more and spending
the mascara the mascara
the mascara
the mascara
if you think someone has mascara on and
you go that mascara
okay that's out um
[Music]
i'm always broke um
you think there might be aliens out
there but they're empty
they're empty they're empty
and i'd be like
did you see that girl get yanked from a
park into the sky
that girl got yeeted into the sky
religious
[Music]
just go just go
online sellers like you need ship
station no matter how much you sell ship
stations
i'm drinking this coffee okay
at new rock stars ship station has
helped save us time on shipping a new
rock
oh my god
you guys that was big question
that was what what a depressing big
question folks so sorry and that's a big
question thank you for joining
[Music]
you